and we might as well explain we were at
uh what is it it was a Premiere and
advanced screening yeah for uh the movie
that you wrote yeah and uh and then MGK
directed it yeah me and minkels yeah me
and Kelsey directed it Colson Baker
Colson Baker which I would have never
called him that in my entire life good I
can't call him Colson dude what do you
call them Kells Kells dude yes we've
known each other for like 12 years and
like I didn't even know he had a first
name until like three years ago right
okay but he introduces himself as Kel uh
Coulson I know
yeah yeah he does now he's uh you know
Dwayne Johnson over here yeah
I'm sure help me remember what was the
name of that movie good morning good
morning and morning it's spelled with
you and we actually shot it coming up
here driving up this Canyon we actually
shot at the house so we shot it at is
like blocks away from here right so I
was over here every day for like two
months at 5 00 a.m and how did that
movie perform it was on Netflix it is no
it's not on Netflix
um it's on uh Amazon Prime it just got
added to American Airlines
yeah do you have a sense of how the
movie performed financially not at all
okay not at all I have I I make money on
it on the back end yet no no
uh I haven't made anything on the back
end of Jackass forever okay so I've got
a long ways to go
I'll be waiting I'll hit you up in 10
years and let you know
um but but uh as far as like you know
it's really like a stoner comedy and
kind of
um the hopes going into it was make like
something that's more of like a cult
classic you know that gets better over
time sure
um we were Scott and I at the the movie
that's where where you introduced
yourself to me and tell me you loved the
podcast we were thoroughly enjoying the
movie but we're both sober nerds yeah
and uh the little screening room that it
was in like I just got so smoked out
I know we're there we're so close to
getting kicked out yeah we're so close
to getting kicked I was just like dude I
can't hear like I don't I just like
I don't care if people drink alcohol
around me because like that's not
entering my body you know like when
people are smoking weed and I'm
breathing it in that's like second hand
I understand that now I can't I I
understand that like I actually do as
like as like uh from like 16 years old
until like two years ago I was like okay
I smoke [__] you talking about it's
getting hot and now I'm like okay yeah I
do understand right yeah I remember I
remember we left there and I was like
[__] that was gnarly and then I kind of
was like I kind of wish I was hot like I
was like I wish I got secondhand high
off that you know it's like a free lap
yeah yeah I mean I don't I don't know
how high you actually
I don't know how high you'd actually get
from that but uh just the idea of it and
what's most upsetting to me about it is
how much I love the smell of weed how
much how much I frankly miss being able
to smoke weed yeah like if I could smoke
weed I would love that's the one thing I
miss doing I totally I would love to be
able to smoke weed I just know that I
can't yeah yeah so yeah whatever I'm
kind of there now too all right yeah
um do you like shopping on Amazon I do
and good news is Stevo's butt wipes for
your butt all are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude